welcome to this video playing risk
junkie from Norway it is no way yes the
Queen's Gambit okay so the chigorin
which I don't know yeah I don't know
in honor on a decent level I know that
Knight f6 and Bishop we should what even
this is a move it looks very strange to
me
how does he does he save this night no
before is the threat I cannot play b6
yeah this this wins at least a piece and
it's more even black resigns okay
this is close to being a record I guess
but at least it serves as a as a warning
if you play the chicharrón you should
know at least a bit of theory
I think Bishop g4 is already beyond
repair after d5 Knight f6 s is the
normal move here for example for Bishop
g4 this kind of this kind of a line but
this I mean probably you need to drop it
back the night I just suggest just not
playable at all if you drop back home
yes this where do you go know what is an
excellent shape and after here I mean I
don't know how to save it the compounds
to play e5 which would have been
interesting at least but look a force
good attending before winning the piece
and it seems that there's no salvation
against that yeah the Shiva ring is the
risk killing anyway and if you play
let's say one bad move in and this you
probably blown away like like in the
game thanks for watching